you know who says you're lying about
vacation who does
alex jones and he wants to call you out
on it
alex jones is mike go ahead alex jimmy
has a time share
at epstein island with gates fauci bezos
and soros and he knows
hollywood has been exposed as a black
hole to another dimension in the gates
to hell
he wants the allegory of the collapse of
society to push the corona hoax
is that not true jimmy are you asking me
all true yeah i have a time share in the
few time shares that
bill gates is involved with you support
fouchy telling people
don't take vitamin d3c take our
militarized testing with bill gates well
to hell i will i will not bow to you
i will not bow to satan uh
listen you made an accusation against a
late night talk show host i don't like
that
well i will say a nice thing good luck
hosting the enemies and good luck
hosting your bilderberg ritual sacrifice
are you going to be presenting the
sacrifice to the al god moloch
or the sub-humanoid baby feast which one
are you doing this year jimmy we're
going to moloch this year
oh lock well listen you need to stop
eating baby meat
and start eating powdered meat yes
we're talking about the liberty food the
buckets
ah powder chicken powdered cookies
powdered eggs old jones family recipe
it'll last for over 300 years with our
natural conservatives anti-freeze
and mulch 40 cent off infowars.com
infowars.com thank you i got a busy show
i gotta go take a piss when we come back
i uh i have some clips i can play from
the reptilian happy hour you might want
to hear that
so stay tuned we'll be back right after
these
words stay tuned thank you thank you
alex
all right there he goes amazing